maybe you've seen this warning lately
it's not good especially for your
phone's battery and but how hot is too
hot action there was only one way to
find out put some phones under a food
heat lamp of course
and
137 degrees and there's the screen
please do not do this at home
for many reasons but mainly heat is
really bad for your phone's battery and
well you may have heard you know the
heat is not backing off and that heat is
not going away heat heat and combine
that environmental heat with processor
intensive tasks and even fast charging
and the phone temps are only going to
rise so why do batteries hate heat and
what temperature triggers the warning
and is there anything you can do about
it and is having a mini phone fan
cool
all right let's heat up some phones and
answer those questions
okay first thing to answer why is heat
so bad for batteries this is a
Lithium-Ion battery from inside an
iPhone I'll spare you the chemistry
class but there's a complicated chemical
reaction that occurs during charging and
discharging as you increase the
temperature the speed of that chemical
reaction also increases that can cause
the battery to drain faster and the
actual battery components and capacity
to degrade over time you can check the
status of your iPhone or Android phone's
battery capacity under settings
but how hot is too hot for a smartphone
battery 95 degrees seems to be the magic
number according to Apple and Android
phone makers like Samsung Apple
specifically says here that exposing
your device to ambient temperatures
higher than 95 degrees Fahrenheit can
permanently damage battery capacity but
that doesn't mean your smartphone will
warn you about overheating at 95 degrees
I decided to test it myself by putting
this iPhone 13 Pro and Samsung Galaxy
s23 Ultra under a heat lamp I took the
temperature readings with this FLIR
thermal camera and an external
thermometer as a backup
the first test was just a phone under
the fake Sun the alert popped up on the
iPhone after baking for 7 minutes and 20
seconds just as the front of the phone's
temperature hit 137 degrees on the
Samsung an alert popped up that the
phone was too warm about seven minutes
in when it was 128 degrees but unlike
Apple's warning Samsung's doesn't limit
you from using the phone it just limits
usage of some parts of the device the
second test I wanted to know if fast
charging which generates heat on its own
would make the temperature rise faster
so I ran the experiment while the phones
were charging with this special cord
that shows the charging speed with both
the iPhone and the Samsung the phones
just slowed the charging speed as they
got warmer oh wait now it's going down
the charging speed both phones had their
alerts pop up around the same
temperature between 130 to 135 degrees
wow very hot very very hot and then
there was the final test recording some
video while under the hot sun this
really sped up the heat because
recording video is a very processor
intensive task the phone is at about 135
degrees and with the video playing it
happened in under five minutes
so what can you do about all this well
don't put your phone under a heat lamp
but sometimes heat happens so here are
some ideas that I test in number one buy
a bag
I bought this 19 thermal bag on Amazon I
put the phones in it and then put it
under the light and oh no okay it is the
thermal bag hit 302 degrees and we
thought let's stop this the phone
totally cool totally fine inside the
thermal bag the maker of the bag a
company called wallphed did not respond
to my request for comment I did try this
30 bag from a company called fuzzi a few
days later and it didn't smoke and it
kept the phone cool so yeah I'd go with
that one number two limit fast charging
and cases Apple and Android phone makers
use software to balance fast charging
with battery longevity and honestly I'd
say the convenience of charging fast is
better than babying your battery but if
you want to slow down go back to this
tiny charging Cube if you have an iPhone
Samsung lets you turn off fast charging
in settings
Apple also suggests removing phone cases
since they can generate excess heat as
well some Android phones are designed to
better handle fast charging though this
OnePlus 10t has a vapor cooling system
so it can charge from zero to a hundred
percent in 20 minutes
number three try a fan obviously that
bag doesn't work if you want to use your
phone so I tried razer's 60 phone cooler
chroma which attaches back here the only
problem with it is that the fan itself
needs to be plugged in still I was blown
away at how cool it kept the phone no
temperature warning on this side it has
been under the lamp for about 10 minutes
look the good news is battery damage
isn't going to just happen from that one
time you left the phone on the beach but
your battery is going to degrade over
time and heat will only speed that up
so stay
there's only one place you're going with
this phone
it's not a rave it's a LAN party